Speaker 1: after Trump was arrested, booked
and arraigned for 37 felony counts related
to classified documents that include obstruction
and other crimes.
Trump flew back to his resort resort, New
Jersey, Bedminster, and he gave a speech.
In this speech, Donald Trump actually admitted
to some of the crimes he is accused of misstated
the law under which he is being prosecuted
wrongly, said other people also committed
the same crimes, which, by the way, it's not
really a defense to say other people have
also committed these crimes.
It's just another form of an admission and
maybe most importantly, really seemed dejected
and as though he is extraordinarily scared,
which reportedly he is really a speech for
the ages which contained this instant classic
line from Trump.
Speaker 2: I did everything right and they
indicted me.
Speaker 1: It is truly beyond parody, but
it is really an important speech because this
speech is admissible.
Legal experts have written overnight that
even if Donald Trump doesn't testify in this
trial or what may be an eventual trial, the
speech he gave last night is admissible as
evidence.
And in last night's speech, he actually admits
to much of what he is accused of doing.
Let's dive right in.
Speaker 3: The sham indictment put forward
by the Biden administration included stage
photographs of boxes at Mar a Lago.
Many people have asked me why I had these
boxes.
Why did you want them?
Speaker 1: So remember, he says the boxes
are staged, but actually they are his boxes.
And now he explains why.
Speaker 3: And so in addition to having every
right under the Presidential Records Act is
that these boxes were containing all types
of personal belongings, many, many things,
shirts and shoes and everything, as can be
seen in the picture where someone, not me,
I wonder who it might have been dumped.
One of the very neatly arranged boxes all
over the floor.
They were full of newspapers, press clippings,
thousands of pictures, thousands and thousands
of White House pictures.
The White House photographer, some are with
us today.
They took so many pictures and we saved all
of them.
And they were in those boxes clothing, memorabilia
and much, much more.
I hadn't had a chance to go through all the
boxes.
It's a long, tedious job.
Takes a long time.
Speaker 1: So understand that amidst the bad
audio and the sniffing from Trump, there are
a bunch of different defenses there.
It's hard to keep track.
He he declassified them when he was president,
except this doesn't have to do when he was
president.
The FBI planted them.
He called them planted boxes.
But ultimately, what Trump is saying is it
was my right to have those.
I simply hadn't gone through them yet because
I was really busy.
That is an admission to some of the critical
facts that I don't believe his lawyers are
even looking to stipulate if this eventually
goes to trial.
Trump digging his own hole.
Trump then referring to his rights as president
of the United States.
But again, it's really important to understand
Trump's getting himself into more trouble
here because he is not indicted for his conduct
as president of the United States.
Speaker 3: The president enjoys unconstrained
authority to make decisions regarding the
disposal of documents.
Speaker 1: That's the problem, is this is
not for things Trump did as president.
And we know he didn't declassify those documents
because there's audio of him saying these
are classified documents from July of 2021
unconstrained.
Speaker 3: To make that decision.
Neither the archivist nor Congress has the
authority to veto the president's decision.
The Presidential Records Act does not confer
any mandatory or even discretionary authority
on the archivist to classify records.
Speaker 1: Folks.
Speaker 3: Under the statute, this responsibility
is left solely to the President of the United
States.
Speaker 1: Donald Trump was not president
when he committed the alleged acts for which
he has been indicted.
This is it seems like just Trump reading stuff
off of one of the very teleprompters he criticizes
others for using.
It seems like it's just more of that.
But legal experts have looked at that 37 second
video clip and come away realizing Trump is
admitting to crimes and he is also stating
law.
Presidential records.
I guess we can call it war.
That is not the law under which he is charged.
And Jack Smith, the special prosecutor, has
Trump on an on a recording saying that the
things he had were still classified, meaning
he knew he did not declassify them.
This is going to become evidence after bemoaning
the politically motivated prosecution against
him in which he claims Joe Biden was involved,
even though there was no evidence Joe Biden
was involved in it.
Trump actually says out loud, out loud.
If he becomes president, he will go after
the Bidens for politically motivated reasons.
Look at this.
Speaker 3: I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president in
the history of the United States of America,
Joe Biden and the entire Biden crime family,
to name a special prosecutor.
Speaker 1: Now, you understand that people
in the background are yelling, lock him up
about Joe Biden.
These are the people who claim Trump wasn't
given due process and they want Biden locked
up, absent forget about an indictment, absent
any evidence of criminal intent, which we
will get back to you.
Speaker 3: And all others involved with the
destruction of our elections, our borders
and our country itself, they're destroying
our country.
And when I'm reelected and we will get reelected,
we have no choice.
We're not going to have a country.
Anymore.
I will totally obliterate the deep state.
We will obliterate.
Speaker 1: The deep state.
So Trump going conspiratorial.
But if you are on the right and you are claiming
that we are a banana republic because Trump
was indicted.
Trump is straight up saying we're going to
go after the Bidens period.
Full stop, no due process, no evidence.
Trump also referred to the documents in question
as his own papers and his own documents.
They are not that I mean, by law, that is
not what they are.
These are the government's documents.
These are the people's documents.
TRUMP Just look, these are my documents.
They're not your documents.
Speaker 3: Charging a former president of
the United States under the Espionage Act
of 1917 wasn't meant for this.
An act for a crime so heinous that only the
death penalty would do, and threatening me
with 400 years in prison for possessing my
own presidential papers, which just about
every other president has done.
Speaker 1: They are not Trump's papers.
They are not Trump's papers.
Sort of mob like Trump attacking the wife
of special prosecutor Jack Smith, just going
after his wife.
Speaker 3: He's a raging and uncontrolled
Trump hater, as is his wife, who also happened
to be the producer of that Michelle Obama
puff piece.
It was total puff piece.
This is the guy you have got.
Speaker 1: Yep.
Going after the wife of the prosecutor claiming
that the DOJ evidence was staged and no other
president.
Speaker 3: Even those who kept far more documents
that he has ever been even investigated, let
alone charged with a crime because the sham
indictment put forward by the Biden administration
included staged photographs of boxes at Mar
a Lago.
Many people have asked me why I had these
boxes.
Speaker 1: Why there is no evidence that the
photographs were staged.
There is no evidence that Joe Biden did a
damn thing.
And then lastly, moving on to Biden.
And Hillary did it, too, which is not a defense.
Speaker 3: This Corvette is story so proud
of that car.
There was no security and the door was left
open.
Most of the time it was open.
All of those classified documents, all of
those documents strewn all over the floor,
piled up like junk, unlike me, who had absolute
declassification authority as President, Joe
Biden as vice president, had no authority
to declassify and no right to possess.
Speaker 1: So the normal stuff, I don't have
to play the whole thing for you.
But blaming Hillary and Biden for doing the
same thing isn't a defense, and it's also
not true.
First and foremost, the Hillary Clinton circumstances.
There was an investigation which concluded
that there was a complete and total lack of
criminal intent.
Remember that the indictment against Trump
involves willfully retaining these documents,
refusing to give them back, lying about having
them, obstructing, going out of his way.
It also includes recordings with alleged conversations
where Trump actually signals that he knows
exactly that those documents are classified.
It is simply not an analogous situation whatsoever
to Hillary Clinton's.
As far as Biden, there's a special counsel
investigating that.
I mean, we we just haven't gotten an answer
one way or the other.
If Biden did something wrong, indict him for
all I care.
But as of right now, saying Biden and Hillary
did it too, is partially premature, completely
incorrect, and dramatically misstates what
Trump has even been indicted for.
Trump's speech will likely be evidence against
him, if you can imagine.
It is clear Trump is not taking advice from
his own lawyers to the extent that he can
even retain lawyers.
After the break, let's see what the Trump
supporters think about all
of this.
We
were on the ground yesterday in Miami, Florida.